[Music]
hello everybody very good morning seven
o'clock here in the uk very welcome to
spend your breakfast with us here at sky
news wherever you're watching us around
the world this morning president biden
has broken his silence over the crisis
in afghanistan and his message over the
u.s withdrawal was one of defiance will
the british government also double down
this morning despite the chaos we've
seen at kabul airport foreign secretary
dominic raab will be here in the studio
in just a few moments time in addition
to that quarter to eight we're joined by
a former british army officer and author
to discuss where the us and uk went
wrong in afghanistan it's tuesday the
17th of august president biden says he
stands squarely behind the afghanistan
withdrawal saying the blame for the
taliban takeover lies elsewhere
american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves
i'm in washington reflecting on a
decision and a speech which could define
joe biden's presidency
coming home in the last few moments
another british evacuation flight has
touched down at raf rise norton
and we're here at rf bryce norton as
british troops get ready to fly out to
afghanistan
and after the chaotic and tragic scenes
at kabul airport yesterday britain and
america are now sending more troops to
secure the runway flights have now
resumed is the mission
to evacuate foreign nationals becomes a
race against time
flown to safety in qatar the image
showing hundreds of afghan refugees
aboard a u.s air force jet
mostly dull and damp for many places
today but there will be some sunshine
for some i'll have details for you later
[Music]
morning everybody the u.s president joe
biden has insisted he stands squarely
behind his decision to withdraw u.s
forces from afghanistan the president
returned from camp david last night to
break his silence on the chaos in kabul
since the taliban seized the city mr
biden called the scenes in kabul
gut-wrenching but he blamed the
taliban's takeover on the afghan
political leaders who fled the country
and the army which he called unwilling
to fight our u.s correspondent mark
stone reports
for a week he's been silent a week in
which a decision that he made has played
out with alarming chaos
now back from his holiday back in the
white house president biden faced the
biggest test of his presidency
i stand squarely behind my decision
after 20 years
i've learned the hard way
that there was never a good time to
withdraw
u.s forces
that's why we're still there
we were clear-eyed about the risk
we plan for every contingency but
i always promise the american people
that i will be straight with you
the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated american troops cannot
and should not
be fighting in a war and dying in a war
that afghan forces are not willing to
fight for themselves the core of his
carefully scripted argument was that
staying there would have been futile
there is no chance
that one year
one more year five more years or 20 more
years
u.s military boots on the ground would
have made any difference
but then what of the timing and the
manner of the us pull out
the scenes were seen in afghanistan
they're
gut-wrenching particularly for our
veterans
our diplomats humanitarian workers for
anyone who has spent time
on the ground working to support the
afghan people
a month ago in the same room words which
now sound so naive is the taliban
takeover of afghanistan now inevitable
no
it is not
there's going to be no circumstance
where you see people being lifted off
the roof
of a
embassy in the of the united states
from afghanistan it is not at all
comfortable
now with an all-american backdrop he
danced a fine line for a home audience
claiming in one breath that this was the
right decision the only decision but
then arguing that he was forced to
follow through on a bad deal with the
taliban struck by donald trump
under his agreement
u.s forces would be out of afghanistan
by may 1
2021.
in other words he argues that his
withdrawal was more controlled than mr
trump's would have been he does know
that a decision that was on him has
caused unease and upset among allies and
more than a wry smile from foes but this
speech wasn't for them
so what now the president had this
we will lead with our diplomacy our
international influence and our
humanitarian aid
will continue to push for regional
diplomacy and engagement to prevent
violence and instability
we'll continue to speak out for the
basic rights of the afghan people of
women and girls
and so it was a doubling down of his
decision no regrets this was a message
for the people of america not for the
people of afghanistan mark stone sky
news in washington
martha's standing by for us in
washington this morning morning to you
martha good evening i suppose where you
are very early as hours of the morning
he came he spoke he left again didn't
take any questions
yeah he left again back to his country
retreat camp david he'd cut his whole
day short in order to make this urgent
address to the american people there was
very little in that speech in the way of
regret or remorse for the scenes that we
see unfolding in afghanistan instead
what we got was a clear-eyed defense of
the decision to withdraw american troops
from afghanistan he said he could not
and he would not send another generation
of america's sons and daughters to war
in afghanistan it was a very emotive use
of language to appeal to an american
audience this wouldn't was an american
centric speech some here have called it
callous and insensitive because there
really was very little to appeal to the
people of afghanistan we did see or we
did hear an acknowledgement that some of
those images that we've seen out of the
country over the last couple of days
have been gut-wrenching he admitted that
the book does stop with him but yet
equally there still wasn't a real
explanation for the chaos we've seen
unfolding in afghanistan given that
there was such a clear timetable for
withdrawal why is it all so frenzied now
and why was there not a better plan put
in place um to extract some of the
afghan citizens who have worked
alongside u.s troops over the past two
decades and it's those images of
desperation um among the afghan people
which are so damaging not only for
america's reputation internationally but
also for president biden's standing
domestically those images
of people clinging to the undercarriage
of u.s air force jets those images of
people running alongside
those same jets in such a desperate
attempt to escape now president biden as
you were mentioning k did use this
speech to to point the finger at various
parties whether that be the the afghan
army who he said were unwilling to fight
whether that be the deal that he
inherited from president trump tonight
we've also heard from another former
president the president who took
america's war in afghanistan president
bush saying that the america have
responsibility and resource to secure
safe passage to afghan citizens now if
president biden is to find anything to
redeem what's been a foreign policy
disaster then it will be finding as many
people as possible as many afghan
citizens as possible safe passage to the
u.s okay for now martha thanks very much
thank you for the update
well in the last few minutes another
british evacuation flight has landed at
raf bryce norton this was the scene
early this morning in oxfordshire as the
raf hercules touched down yesterday the
foreign secretary dominic robb said 150
british nationals would be arriving back
in the uk in the early hours of this
morning the foreign secretary said a
further 350 britons and afghan nationals
will be arriving in the coming days
while another 200 british soldiers will
be heading to kabul to support the
evacuation our correspondent charlotte
lomas is at raf brises norton in
oxfordshire for us this morning hello to
you charlotte so another plane with more
relieved people on board
absolutely and we are expecting more
british armed force troops to head out
in the other direction and head out to
afghanistan we know the numbers have
risen to 900 with a further 200 troops
being announced by the ministry of
defence today now that is the push to
try and bring more uk nationals home but
also to secure the safety of selected
afghans and this decision does come
after those frantic scenes that we saw
at kabul airport that martha just
touched on there in her correspondence
with you
just really trying to make controlling
the airport easier so hoping by adding
additional troops and sending more
british troops out there that will
assist in the evacuation from
afghanistan
okay charlotte thank you
foreign secretary is with us in the
studio now hello to foreign secretary
thanks for joining us on the program
this morning um to the outside world it
appears what's going on in kabul is
absolute chaos what's your understanding
well i got a situation update this
morning the uh position at the airport
is stabilizing there's been a surge of
us and uk troops we've got 600 extra
personnel there it's critically
important not just for the stability on
the ground for afghans but critically
for our evacuation effort
we've made real progress we had 150
british nationals come out on sunday
over the last week we've also had 289
of those afghan nationals who have
served the uk so loyally in afghanistan
and we expect over the next 24 hours to
have 350 more both british nationals and
afghan nationals have worked for us
coming out so the situation is
stabilizing but obviously we're
monitoring it very carefully ben wallace
told me yesterday and again last friday
that we needed something like 1500
people a day to come out
well it it depends if you're talking
about the arap program or nationals
we've had uh and there's no does it it's
chaos though we need to get them out
well actually i think getting our
british nationals out of course there's
something like uh 2000 that the figure
is changing all the time who have
contacted us so that's a much smaller
figure in terms of our app yes we want
to we want to get all of those out as
well arab of course is those whether
it's translators or other afghans who
loyally serve the uk so doing everything
we can but obviously it depends on the
security situation on the ground
that's why we're putting in 600 of our
own personnel i spoke to tony blink and
the u.s secretary of state yesterday
they're upping every hour and every day
the security that they need including
crowd control to deal with the surge of
afghans what happened yesterday who who
who are
seeking to get out
given the taliban takeover what happened
yesterday well i think given the taliban
takeover given the nervousness the fear
on the ground you've seen a lot of
people effectively heading for the door
and we've got to make sure that we can
stabilize the situation and i think
ultimately british people would expect
us and i'm sure the american public the
same to prioritize our nationals uh
including dual nationals in afghanistan
uh but also those who have so lowly
served us that's what we're doing okay
um a large number of thugs is what i
read in this morning's newspapers that
are on their way to kabul uh this uneasy
piece that is in place at the moment is
very soon going to be shattered what's
your intelligence on that well we don't
talk about intelligence as you know you
must be concerned about it though well
there are reports all the time the
situation is very fluid the taliban have
uh
exerted control far more rapidly than we
expect there will be uh dissenting rebel
uh uh voices and actions uh what we want
to see at the moment is two things one
the evacuation conducted as stably as
possible we've had assurances uh at the
higher level from uh the taliban uh
through uh publicly through the taliban
political commission doha in three or
third parties i spoke to the qatari
foreign minister and the
pakistani foreign minister um they've
made all sorts of commitments in the
doha agreement which dates back to 2020
we expect to hold into account to that
and secondly then there is the
medium-term strategy which must mean
making sure that afghanistan can't be
used by terrorist groups to attack
neighbours or the west again
trying to provide the humanitarian
relief that the people in afghanistan
need given the hugely unstable situation
you've described
that's going to be very challenging we
won't obviously be giving aid directly
to the taliban we do want to provide
humanitarian relief
to the civilian population and i think
there's a much broader question about
stabilizing that region and how we
engage
with those countries who are going to be
very difficult but will have a stake in
trying to stabilize the situation from
pakistan india to china all with very
different views we've got to show the
international leadership to
try and bring some stability in a
positive track more than that ken
mccallum the head of mi5 is very worried
about uk based groups which um have been
radicalized that could cause problems
here in the uk how weird are you about
that well look we listened to ken and
the home secretary in the law
enforcement operations here attract that
very very carefully of course what
happens in the middle east we know
can have a ricochet effect back in the
uk but what i do know is that
ken and the mi5 team and all of our law
enforcement are absolutely red-hot on
making sure that we protect british
nationals and uh the uk that's our
number one priority
right to be worried ben wallace says he
is i think it's always right the head of
mi5 is alert and sensitive to all
changes abroad that will have a security
implication in the uk
okay um i want to go back to uh the
people that are coming out um of
afghanistan i've been speaking to a lot
of your colleagues they're absolutely
furious that they say about 20 000
afghan nationals need to return to the
uk because they are either people that
work for us directly or their families
who are in extreme danger if they stay
there yeah is that the sort of number
that you're looking at well the the
total numbers are being processed by uh
through the arab scheme we've got 3
300 afghan
nationals and their families out to date
i think we're the highest
number uh proportionately of all of our
allies so i think it's been very
difficult but we've made good progress
we want to now stabilize that airport
and get as many of them out as we
possibly can but yeah but but look but
locate that number but well i'm not sure
about the number exactly but look
they're clearly in the thousands because
we've got 3 300 out already we want to
get as many of them as we physically can
out but of course it depends on the
stable stability of the situation on the
ground which is why we come back to the
point that you mentioned earlier rightly
the stability at the airport is
absolutely key and i've been working
very closely with ben wallace and the
home secretary to make sure we can do
everything we can give ourselves the
capacity every day to get as many out as
as quickly as we can given the uh the
window of opportunity for that do you
agree with your defence secretary that
sadly some people will be left behind i
think there's always a risk of that what
i'm focused on is just doing everything
physically possible to get british
nationals out to get as many of those
have loyally served us out
and also to think about how we then move
forward with an international strategy
which can stabilize the situation for
the people of afghanistan under what
time scale are you hoping to be able to
do that i think it's difficult to say
because the situation is so fluid we
were all caught by a surprise by the
speed and pace and scale of the taliban
takeover the americans have talked about
the end of august but ultimately we need
to get people out as quickly as possible
as soon as possible and it will depend
on the security situation on the ground
but come back to the point i do think
and having spoken to tony blinker my
opposite number yesterday do think that
the the airport is is more stable today
than it was yesterday and we need to
make sure that we consolidate that uh in
the days ahead okay um given that you
said that not just you but many were
taken by surprise not least the
americans as well how disappointed are
you that our military top brass um
didn't know that this was coming
well it's not just a question by the way
of the military we have a
an assessment process uh we've looked at
it for uh if you since i become foreign
secretary i've been in the nsc's
national security council meetings we've
monitored this very carefully but the
truth is uh across the world people were
caught by surprise i haven't spoken to
an international interlocutor including
countries in the region over the last
week who hasn't been surprised um but
the reality is predict better after 20
years in the country well yeah but that
we we saw a very uh swift change in the
dynamics and of course this has been
part and parcel of the withdrawal of uh
western troops um
but it's also been the way and the
approach of the taliban and and of
course it's been a test for the afghan
security forces all of those factors
have been very fluid but no one saw this
coming uh of course we would have taken
action if we had but i i get that my
question is shouldn't we have
i i think it's easy to say that with the
benefit of hindsight but the truth is
you're always measuring a very fluid
constellation matrix if you like of risk
factors and uh
that's the reality
is the taliban an organization that you
can do business with
ordinarily you'd say no um or they don't
share our standards of human rights they
don't just deal with china they don't
treat women the way that doesn't deal
with china well i think we're going to
have to be pragmatic as the uk policy
has always been uh we've engaged
through the political commission of the
taliban in doha it's important we
engaged through third parties that's why
i spoke to my qatari foreign minister
we're going to need to be able to send
clear messages and our message is going
to be this afghanistan must never be
used to launch terrorist
terrorist attacks against the west we've
had 20 years of success
in that regard we've had a range of
other successes we've seen 10 million
more children in education that never
saw a school book since 2001 many of
those young girls we've uh we've cleared
8 million landmines so we have secured
gains in that 20 years clearly they're
now at risk what we want to do is
everything we can through the full range
of diplomatic economic sanction measures
to make sure we can use as much leverage
as we conceivably have and i'm realistic
about that to try and moderate and
exercise some form of positive influence
around the regime ahead and of course
there is still and it may be a low low
chance of this still these talks that
are going on through the taliban's
political commission which is based in
doha to try and make sure that there's a
transitional government which isn't just
purely taliban now i think we need to be
released can't trust the taliban surely
you can't but at least as long as
there's a process that they're engaged
in i think we need to test it they're a
ragtag bunch of thugs
look at they
i'm not going to dissent from that view
but they are now in power and we now
need to deal with that reality and as
all i'm just saying is we don't have to
be optimistic about it as long as there
is an engagement by that process we want
to test uh whether there is scope to
moderate the kind of regime that we will
now see in place do we rule out
returning to afghanistan in some numbers
at some stage in the future
okay i can't uh take a crystal ball out
and i'm scared i'm just saying are you
going to rule that out we we we look we
we seems what biden's done we're clearly
withdrawing we said when we went into
afghanistan nato said we'd go in
together we adapted together and we'd
leave together
so we now need to deal with that reality
how sorry are you that you didn't return
from your holiday idea okay as i said
everyone was caught um
off guard by the pace scale of the
taliban takeover um the reality is as a
foreign secretary all foreign
secretaries are in this position when
we're abroad whether it's for travel
for work or for holiday we are there
able to respond to events so i was
engaged in cobra talking to foreign
counterparts directly
speaking to the head of our team here in
london i was doing that on an hour by
hour basis and of course i left
as soon as the situation deteriorated
and demanded it
understood but you um and the prime
minister i mean you're the de facto uh
deputy prime minister the prime minister
both of you on holiday at the same time
while afghanistan was going to hell in a
handcart
was that a dereliction of duty no i
don't think that's uh that's the the
right description look the reality is
would you describe it well look we we've
been monitoring the situation in
afghanistan uh since the 2020 doha
agreement very carefully it's been very
fluid from my point of view at any num
what point in time i will have eight to
ten simmering issues that can bubble up
uh and we always know not like this yes
yes yes yes i'm afraid okay may not
always be in the media eye but actually
situations where we have to give a very
close eye i always have to be one of the
biggest airlifts since the second world
war well and but we didn't predict uh
that we would be doing this on this
scale because of the taliban takeover
but look in retrospect of course i
wouldn't have gone on holiday if i'd
named that being the case equally after
um 18 months and two years of a very uh
grueling demanding schedule i think it's
right the people in those positions try
and take some leave but we're always
ready i'm always ready uh to come back
and of course the key point that i was
making is even when i was away frankly i
wouldn't have gone away if i don't know
that i was constantly uh handling and
managing meetings uh talking to foreign
counterparts and uh because of
technology of course able to engage in
every one of the cobra meetings i was
speaking to a former soldier yesterday
who lost both of his legs um in
afghanistan he said he picked up bits of
his mate on the road in afghanistan he
says that it was all for nothing
my heart goes out to anyone that has
served their country and suffered those
kind of losses and seen what he would
have seen
he has served his country loyally and i
think he should be proud of what he's
achieved as i mentioned before we're
there 20 years
we have
in that time not seen a terrorist group
attack the west from afghanistan we have
seen but what's going to happen hold on
let's but he about it wasn't all for
nothing 10 million uh girl uh children
in education many of them girls uh eight
million landmines clear we did that with
our partners just so you know for
mothers the
the maternal fatality rate so the number
of mothers that lost their life in
childbirth or in pregnancy down by
almost a half but what now so we
achieved those things but now the
question is with the taliban in place
and and what are the levers we've got to
moderate what comes next and to make
sure that the gains aren't lost what do
you think so first my my my answer to
him would be his his service was not in
vain but we've got a you know hell of a
challenge now we will use all the levers
that we've got whether it's uh economic
tools sanctions the diplomatic leverage
i think what's going to be important in
the terms of the diplomacy is working
with all the countries in the region as
well as the traditional partners in
india mata china and russia will matter
difficult interlocutors for us pakistan
will matter all of those have got to
with us work to provide some stability
and we've started that in the security
council we use our g7 presidency we'll
use the un general assembly coming up in
september i think we need a contact
group
of those regional and key partners and i
think we need to see uh some
international leadership and we'll be
working very closely with the un and
those partners to achieve that i must
let you go thank you for being open and
honest as always thank you good to talk
to you thank you
um let's bring in our middle east
correspondent alistair bunkel shall we
who's standing by for us this morning
hello to alastair very good morning your
thoughts good morning
good morning kay uh well look let's
first start off with uh doubling
assessment of the situation on the
ground this morning uh sounds like more
positive uh news at kabul airport uh the
only caveat i would say is i think uh my
memory tells me correctly
things were rather calmer uh this time
yesterday morning before they started
spiraling out of control as the day wore
on but i think the
introduction of more us and british
troops when they arrive will help uh
that security operation
to keep the runway clear and to allow
military flights to arrive and take off
again and if we get to a situation uh
where flights are able to come in and
out with some regularity then i think
we'll see a far
swifter operation to help repatriate the
foreigners who are stuck in
kabul um the second point that i picked
up on was a slight change of tone i
detected in the potential future
approach towards
in the last days and weeks the message
from the
international community from the west
was very much that the taliban would not
be internationally recognized as a
government
my personal view on that was always that
that was somewhat short-sighted because
they didn't really take into account
what russia and china perhaps pakistan
uh iran would uh do with with the
taliban and already we've seen russia
and china reach out tentatively towards
the new taliban administration um
however dominic rav in that interview
with you there suggesting uh that they
would if possible look at ways of um
having some sort of dialogue some sort
of interaction with the taliban
government is very early days or we
don't even know the makeup of the
taliban administration yet um and you do
have that third-party conduit in qatar
to deal with if necessary but i just
felt it was a slight change of tone that
um if the british government feels that
it can not not do business with not do
trade deals with not not become uh
partners with but if british government
feels that it can have some sort of
relationship with the taliban
then that might be something they pursue
and as i say i think that is a slight
change to tone
okay alastair for now thank you
still to come on the program for you
president biden doubles down on the us
withdrawal next i'll be speaking to a
member of his predecessor donald trump's
national security council half-past
eight will be speaking to a u.s war
veteran about the current state of
afghanistan following president biden's
decision to withdraw u.s troops
and in case you missed it last night
later in the programme we'll have a full
replay of president biden's defiant
address to the nation that's at 9 30
this morning
looking at the morning's other news
news stories for you now and heavy rain
has begun to batter haiti as the country
tries to recover from a recent
earthquake which killed more than 1 400
people forecasters think up to 15 inches
of rain could fall during tropical
depression grace families have tried to
escape the rain at a makeshift camp for
people whose homes collapsed during the
quake
bob dylan has been accused of historical
sex abuse allegations dating back more
than 50 years the singer-songwriter is
being sued over claims he molested a
12-year-old girl in new york in 1965.
a spokesperson for dylan who's now 80
said the allegations were false and will
be vigorously defended
government launching a plan to cut
emissions by using hydrogen as an
alternative to oil and gas it's hoped
hydrogen will play a key role in cutting
carbon in energy intensive industries
and could account for up to 35 percent
of the uk's energy consumption by 2050.
right what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned now's is standing
by for us this morning looking gorgeous
as always good morning nurse
good morning thank you kay um weather's
not looking so gorgeous it's looking
quite dull and damp in fact for many
places today but a lucky few seeing some
sunny spells
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's a dull and damp affair
for the rest of this week across much of
the uk and ireland there will be a few
breaks in the cloud at times allowing
for some sunny spells but it's also
going to be quite cool for the time of
years we continue with the northerly
flow now at the moment most places
starting off quite cloudy some patches
of mist fog also light rain and drizzle
quite persistent downpours across
northern parts of england and wales and
eastern parts of england too now going
into this afternoon we will continue to
see patchy light rain and drizzle
particularly across parts of the
northwest of england and wales northern
ireland the north of the republic too
the rain across eastern parts of england
tending to ease slowly away but
generally cloudy and dumped there today
scotland on the other hand becoming dry
and brighter and there will be some
breaks in the cloud for southwestern
parts of the uk and ireland where we're
likely to see the highest temperatures
today but obviously under the cloud
cover and the drizzly rain it will be
feeling much cooler elsewhere
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
again u.s president joe biden has
insisted that he stand squarely behind
his decision to withdraw u.s forces from
afghanistan addressing the nation last
night he added that american troops
should not fight a war afghan forces are
not willing to fight themselves
robert spalding a former member of
president trump's national security
council joining us now from washington
hello to you sir thanks for joining us
on the program this morning i believe
that you agree uh with what president
biden has been saying what about the
turmoil that's been left behind
well i think um as i said i agree with
um you know essentially
most of what joe biden said during his
uh announcement about afghanistan i
think that the challenge is that
this was poorly planned um it could have
gone much better and i think you know
the pentagon certainly the intelligence
community
really i think in this case let the the
president down because i think it was
well known that as um we said we were
going to depart this this thing was
going to collapse very very quickly
president trump wanted them out um in
may didn't he
well yes but there there's also a way
that you get out and that is if you
remember in the announcement that
president biden made
we said you know the afghan government
asked us not to evacuate people because
they didn't want to cause a crisis of
confidence well
in allowing the afghanistan government
what they wanted and then the
afghanistan government fled the the
country it really led to this chaos and
so i think what we should have done is
actually plan for this collapse and then
we would have been much better
prepared than having to spend an
additional 6 000 troops and you see the
chaos on the ground it doesn't help when
a previous president gives the enemy the
timeline though
well again it doesn't matter the
timeline what matters are you prepared
for the conditions that are going to
come
that's why we do tremendous planning in
the military to in order to
you know prepare for these eventualities
it's clear that their planning was not
done to ensure a proper evacuation of
the country this is not about timelines
this is really about what was planned
for
but if you leave it in fact if you
organize an evacuation do you not leave
a vacuum what does that mean for the
people left behind you take away
you leave them with the firepower i
suppose and certainly the hardware but
you take away the manpower
ultimately this is afghanistan's country
it's it's for their government and their
people to decide the fate of afghanistan
it's not for the united states or any
other country and i think we spend a lot
of time a lot of money a lot of lives
really what we need to do and what i
think democracies everywhere need to do
is focus on their citizens ensure that
they're prosperous that they're safe
that they're free and i think in doing
so we're going to show the rest of the
world why democracy is such a good you
know way to go you know what's happened
since the end of the cold war is we've
focused on external wars we've focused
on peace everywhere and tried to fight
for that peace in reality what we should
have been is building building
democracies like we did after the end of
world war ii throughout the cold war we
stopped doing that when the cold war
ended
it didn't work well in afghanistan did
it trying to build a democracy it's a
country that you invaded two decades ago
summarily dissected um and look what's
happened now
when i say building i'm talking about
things like the marshall plan i'm
talking about the rebuilding of japan
and korea after world war ii i'm talking
about the focus on innovation technology
talent and capital being going into
democracies after world war ii the thing
that won the cold war was not fighting
it was not war
it was the building of democracies and
the prosperity of individuals in those
democracies citizens really that really
led to the collapse of the soviet union
the soviet union didn't collapse because
of our military mind the soviet union
collapsed because we had a more
compelling model today the innovation
technology talent capital from
democracies has gone over to
authoritarian governments primarily
china and have been used to displace
workers and have really led to the
demise of democracy for the last 30
years and so if we're going to rebuild
and that's really what the trump
administration's national security
strategy was about rebuilding
democracies we have to actually build
when you say building democracy in
afghanistan fighting a war in
afghanistan is not building democracy
building democracies building
infrastructure manufacturing science and
technology investing in education those
are the things that we invested in
during the cold war
but soldiers can transform into
peacekeepers for a country that is
basically a fledgling country it's only
two decades old to all intents and
purposes the teenagers who are in uh
kabul and wider afghanistan now haven't
known life under the taliban they wear
jeans they you know they play on their
video games they haven't known what it
was like under um the taliban they're
going to have to find out very quickly
indeed what's the us going to do just
wash their hands of those young people
now
well i think one of the issues that
you're talking about particularly this a
good example would be japan macarthur
actually ran japan as
the the ruling authority for
a long time the united states really
stayed there we're still there we're
still in japan we're still in germany so
what you're what you're suggesting is
the united states should stay in
afghanistan and i think what the
president said is correct in that is
that the united states has no national
security incentive to stay in
afghanistan
if the people in if in afghanistan
aren't willing to actually fight for
themselves and i think this is accurate
you know japan stood up germany stood up
they're a thriving democracy afghanistan
in particular because of its association
with pakistan and the fact that the
pakistan isi
is supporting the taliban and terrorists
was never going to be a thriving
democracy no matter how many decades the
united states was there
in order for to fix afghanistan you
would have have to also fought pakistan
there's no way
either the united states or any of its
allies and partners wanted to do that
okay um i think i'm right in saying that
a third
of the afghan population is under the
age of 18. what about them
well again it's up to the government of
afghanistan if the
international
um you know if the u.n if the
international order wants to move in and
i don't think they do in fact china has
made it very clear that they want to
partner with uh the the taliban saudi
arabia has recognized the taliban
government i think what we have to do
today if we're going to really
look for making people's lives better in
this world we have to focus on showing
that our model the model of democracy
the model of free trade the model where
we take care of our citizens is a better
model we're not going to get there by
invading countries and then trying to
make them like us we have to inspire
them we have to inspire them to want the
kind of lives that we have because our
citizens
live great lives that is the promise of
democracy that's what our national
security is built on is what we can
deliver for our own citizens in our own
countries we appreciate you staying up
late to talk to us on the program this
morning thank you so much for joining us
thank you
thank you thank you just um confirming
in 2019 uh 42.47
of afghanistan's population was under
the age of 14.
speaking on the program a little earlier
the foreign secretary dominic raab said
the situation at cabell airport is being
stabilized and good progress is being
made on the evacuation of british
nationals and afghans and he told me the
uk government will engage with the
taliban through third parties despite
admitting that the uk would not
ordinarily do business with them
they don't share our standards of human
rights they don't
they don't treat women the way that
doesn't deal with china well i think
we're going to have to be pragmatic as
the uk policy has always been
we've engaged uh
through the political commission of the
taliban in doha it's important we engage
through third parties that's why i spoke
to my qatari foreign minister we're
going to need to be able to send clear
messages and our message is going to be
this afghanistan must never be used to
launch terrorist
terrorist attacks against the west we've
had 20 years of success
in that regard we've had a range of
other successes we've seen 10 million
more children in education that never
saw a school book since 2001 many of
those young girls we've uh
we've cleared 8 million land mines so we
have secured gains in that 20 years
clearly they're now at risk what we want
to do is everything we can through the
full range of diplomatic economic
sanction measures to make sure we can
use as much leverage as we conceivably
have and i'm realistic about that to try
and moderate and exercise some form of
positive influence around the regime
ahead and of course there is still and
it may be a low low chance of this still
these talks that are going on through
the taliban's political commission which
is based in doha to try and make sure
that there's a transitional government
which isn't just purely taliban now i
think we need to be released can't trust
the taliban surely you can't but at
least as long as there's a process that
they're engaged in i think we need to
test it they're a ragtag bunch of thugs
look at the they
i'm not going to dissent from that view
but they are now in power and we now
need to deal with that reality
tamara is here thoughts tomorrow well
dominic raab essentially admitting that
we need to deal with the taliban not
directly through third parties and as if
possible as an international community
but this is not back to the 1990s where
they were pariahs now that there is this
threat from terrorism he conceded that
events abroad can ricochet back to the
uk in terms of radicalization we've had
a warning today from the director of mi5
about that and he says we will need to
deal with them through a process in
order to try and prevent it becoming a
haven for al qaeda again but clearly his
immediate focus in the next couple of
days is the evacuation he said that 2000
british nationals remain in afghanistan
i think that's a bit less than we
thought but he says those numbers are
changing all the time and urged people
there to make themselves known to the
authorities it did seem to give hope to
the suggestions that interpreters and
their families and others that have
worked for the british government uh or
the british people will be able to come
back as well look he says that over 3
000 are already in britain that is over
the long term the rules eased up a bit
in may and there was criticism that the
rules were too tight that people who'd
worked for private contractors or had
been made redundant from their jobs were
not able to come over now we've seen
this scramble we know that there have
been home office officials sent out to
kabul airport to help skim through all
these applications because as senior
government officials make clear we need
to do those checks to make sure we're
not allowing the wrong people onto the
planes but certainly as ben wallace
broke down yesterday an interview saying
we're not going to get everybody because
the conditions on the ground taliban
roadblocks in kabul are simply going to
make it too difficult for people who
haven't got their paperwork in place to
do so okay thanks tomorrow uh tomorrow's
take at nine o'clock this morning
meantime as the blame game continues
over afghanistan going to be speaking to
a former british army officer about
where it all went wrong
[Music]
we've been hearing from the foreign
secretary this morning he tells us that
the situation in kabul particularly the
airport is much calmer this morning
and another aircraft has landed at raf
bryce norton with more relieved people
arriving back in the uk
the political blame game over the uh the
failings in afghanistan continues
meantime uh let's get the very latest
now should we uh with uh mike martin uh
who is uh an author of an intimate war
hello gee thanks very much indeed for
joining us on the programme this morning
what do you make of the speed
in which the taliban managed to take
over kabul
uh it's been absolutely blistering um
and it's
you know the foreign said that he was
surprised at the speed at which it was
done the taliban was surprised at the
speed at which it was done um i think
that one point that is important to make
is that
this wasn't so much a taliban victory as
a government collapse
the government in afghanistan just
completely collapsed
without the uh effectively the western
firepower
supporting it
how can the top brass not have known
that that was going to happen both in
the uk and the u.s given that they've
been on the ground for two decades they
know these people they know who's in
charge of the government or previous
government
yeah i i think
our generals are military people
obviously they're not politicians but
the failure in afghanistan was actually
a political one so we we went about how
we wanted to reconstruct afghanistan in
quite a technical way you know clinics
built um you know schools built
elections run so on and so forth
what we the coalition failed to do
was to
um
support or force the afghan government
to build a broad-based enough political
coalition of all the
clans tribes warlords militias and
afghans very afghanistan's very
factionalized um we the afghan
government didn't build a strong enough
political coalition and that meant that
the taliban were able to peel off
members in different provinces and
districts of the government's security
apparatus into their coalition um and
finally with that weak
edifice without foundations that the
western constructed the manner of our
exit the speed at which it was conducted
the leaving of bagram air base in the
middle of the night the forcing of the
afghan government to release taliban
prisoners by the united states
effectively uh gave this house of cards
a shove and it collapsed almost as fast
as the former president who allegedly
has left the country with several
airplanes and cars full of money um what
what has he left behind you talked about
the taliban being able to peel off
certain factions but we had um someone
who i'm sure you'll know the um the
leader of the defense select committee
to buy a zellwood on the program
yesterday um and lord daniel as well
both saying um that now we need to worry
about a civil war
it's too early to tell um certainly the
predictions that many of us were making
myself included that have all turned out
to be wrong were that this would
probably stalemate um
by october
um there are certainly questions about
the degree to which the taliban are
fragmented they
you know like every country the
very factionalized political parties are
made up of different constituencies but
in within the taliban there are real
questions over
uh what their relationship with china is
going to be for instance because of
china's persecution of the uyghurs
what's their policy on drugs what's
their policy on women
i
bring to you that this morning the
afghan news networks restarted again
with female anchors are just now wearing
slightly more conservative headscarfs
and so the different factions the
taliban have these very different views
on uh what constitutes sharia god's law
islam all the rest of it and so that is
a real question i think the other
question is and this is why we haven't
seen the taliban government being
announced
is
that they are trying to invite uh
non-talibs to be ministers so the
taliban will of course handle security
um defense religious affairs but other
portfolios uh i don't know the ministry
of infrastructure may well go to
non-talibs and so i think what's going
on now is the taliban leadership are
trying to build up a cabinet that is
acceptable to their
many fragmented factions as well as
acceptable to the international
community and so this is where we start
to see players like hamid karzai who i'm
sure many of you are listeners will
remember the former president of
afghanistan he perhaps might be you know
some people are touting him as the new
foreign minister
to help the taliban government uh gain
the international recognition that
dominic robb was talking about earlier
okay mike martin good to talk to you
thanks for joining us on the program